hello readers today I want to talk all
about me well I want to talk about three
things first I want to talk all about me
then I'm gonna talk about you and then
we're gonna talk about them David what
are you talking about you're probably
asking well in a word POV in three words
point of view every story has a point of
view it's being told to us by someone a
narrator but who is that narrator
understanding the answer to that
question in the stories that you read
will make you a strong reader there are
three different flavors of point of view
first second and third person first
person is when the narrator is a
character in the story they use words
like I me and my here's an example I
bolted out of bed grabbed my backpack
and rushed out the door today was the
day I was finally going to learn to ride
a horse first-person narrators can only
tell us the parts of the story that they
experienced or already know about if
something happens that the narrator
doesn't know about we the reader won't
know about it either
second person is when you are a
character in the story this is pretty
rare
a lot of the choose your own adventure
books that were popular when I was a kid
use second person point of view but
they're not as big as they used to be
imagine a guided relaxation recording
when you think of second person you are
calm your breathing is slow and even you
are sitting on a bed looking at the
ocean the ocean is calm and so are you
this kind of point of view usually
sounds like it's giving directions to
you the reader the most common point of
view in stories is the third person a
narrator who isn't a character in the
story a third person narrator uses words
like he/she and Vey for characters in
the story instead of I or you it lets
the storyteller get inside the heads of
characters to see how they're feeling or
what they're thinking here's an example
Benny
and his closet door to grab a jacket
only to be greeted by a horrifying
monster he screamed and ran out of the
room scared out of his mind inside her
monster costume Rita giggled
she had tricked her brother see how we
can follow both Rita and Benny the
narrator can see what both of them are
thinking or feeling at the same time now
imagine if that little snippet we're
told from Rita or Benny's first-person
perspectives
Rita using AI or Benny using AI instead
of a third person POV using he or she we
might see it differently reading that
story from Rita's perspective it's a
funny prank from Benny's it's super
scary he just saw a monster so to recap
there are three different types of
narration or points of view in a story
first person the narrator is a character
inside the story and uses words like I
or me second person the narrator is
speaking directly to you the reader and
uses the pronoun you this is rare and it
sounds like it's giving directions and
third person the narrator is outside the
story in telling it they use words like
he/she and they what's the POV of your
favorite story is it first person second
or third how would it feel different if
it were told from a different point of
view with the narrator know different
things I can tell you one thing I know
for certain and that's that you can
learn anything Dave it out